well of course there's no way around it
we're still in the middle of a pandemic
and if that wasn't bad enough now more
contagious variants of covet 19 are
popping up
around the world so as you can imagine
it's more important than ever to stay
safe now one of the easiest ways to do
that
is by wearing a mask i know we've been
talking about this for almost a year
but a lot of people still aren't doing
it you've got to wear a mask until we
make it all the way through
this mess so with that in mind
i'd like my audience to set an example
for the rest of the country
andy i i think it's a great idea i mean
it's
it's a point that still needs to be made
i agree 100
andy so if you're watching from home
that's right i'm talking directly to you
go ahead
and please put on a mask no no no wait
where are you going
come on back i get it i know mass can be
a little uncomfortable but it's for
everyone's safety
okay i see you have asthma huh that's
the idea
doesn't matter health officials say
people with asthma should wear face
masks as well so please for all of our
sakes
just put on a mask great
thank you all right let's do the show uh
this week all eyes are on washington dc
as congress prepares for a
senate what's the matter oh your lenses
are fogging up
just take off your glasses yeah
god your eyesight is horrible
all right put the glasses back on but
uh then tuck your mask under your
glasses
okay see that's a little trick
anyway the whole world is watching to
see if congress will convict
president trump despite i'm sorry what
is going on
have you been drinking don't lie to me
have you been drinking i thought so
i don't blame you it's been a very
stressful time a lot of people are using
alcohol to lower their anxiety
a lot of people are drinking to
self-medicate and it's a perfectly
normal reaction to what
what are you high too are you
drunk and high no
no sorry i do not want to hit no that's
just not my thing
okay all right just take it take it easy
take it easy just cut what no no i love
you too
i know i love you too man i love you too
yeah your hands don't match but i love
you too
just just settle down okay just just go
back to your couch just relax
okay have a seat on the couch i'm
excited about tonight's show we have a
great one
tonight mike berbiglia
is joining us wait no no no just be
careful
be careful i don't want you to no no no
don't hold it
don't don't pass out on me don't pass
out okay just
just take it easy just breathe keep the
mask on but
breathe deep breaths all right we'll
take a break when we come back mike
berbeglia is with us stick around
[Music]